you don't need to kind of mindlessly
drift into the accumulation of stuff and
the derivation of self-worth and the
signaling of one's worth by what one has
instead to kind of just mindful II
realize that the free market offers all
kinds of great stuff hi I'm Nicolas be
with reason TV and today we're talking
with William Irwin he is a professor of
philosophy at King's College in
Pennsylvania and the author of the
free-market existentialist capitalism
without consumerism you write that you
are a lonely man because you are the
only person who is both an
existentialist and a libertarian or a
free marketer what do you mean by
existentialist in this count in this
concept and free marketer I'm the only
one in academic philosophy who I know
who both identifies as an existentialist
and as the libertarian someone in favor
of the free market and why that is I
suppose goes all the way back to the the
arch existentialist jean-paul Sartre and
his early writing which is what I draw
on is very much in favor of the
individual and is very much a political
but after World War 2 along with his
French existentialist cohort drifted
toward socialism and indeed communism
and Sartre was a I mean he was an
apologist not just for Marxism but for
stalinism and the Soviet Union for a
very long time yeah and from now ISM in
particular as well it's just always
puzzled me out and then people take from
that the idea that there must be some
necessary connection between
existentialism and kind of command
economies that's right it certainly
seems that way within within the
academic realm although I think anyone
who simply reads the the two traditions
of existentialism and free market making
on their own can see a natural link
between them but i like to say there's a
those about as much between in common
between existentialism and socialism as
there is between existentialism and
cigarettes they happen to go together
sociologically and certain time place
but there's no larger
oh connection and when you talk about a
free market so if you're talking about
libertarianism define a little bit what
you mean by libertarian in that context
essentially the idea that the government
should play only the role of protecting
us from force fraud and theft complete
unfettered free markets in that way as a
way for allowing a complete individual
freedom and complete individual
responsibility the subtitle of the book
is capitalism without consumerism you're
not against buying and selling stuff but
you are against consumerism what do you
mean by just consumerism well by
consumerism I essentially mean buying
without buying mindfully and consumerism
seems to be this almost addictive drive
to find one's own Worth and signal one's
own worth to others by what one buys and
that conflicts with the the
existentialist imperative to define
yourself and not be defined by what you
buy or by outside forces a can is 0 is
is the charge of consumerism which is
usually seen as one of the ways to
invalidate capitalism is that it creates
consumerism is it really a canard that
is foist adan capitalism by kind of
people who hate capitalism because I
mean do we know many people who really
are consumer us in the way that you
describe it there certainly is a
caricature of consumerism and the
consumerist which you'll find very few
instances of I suppose but but it can be
sort of insidious the way in which one
takes a job of a certain kind and feels
they need a certain car that goes along
with that job and a certain zip code
that goes along with that etc and I
guess all I'm saying is that you don't
need to kind of mindlessly drift into
the accumulation of stuff and the
derivation of self-worth and the
signalling of one's worth by what one
has instead to kind of just mindful II
realize that the free market offers all
kinds of great stuff but it also offers
all kinds of tempting junk
may not be helpful to you talk a little
bit about how you stumbled into this is
so this I mean it's kind of interesting
you you're combining two areas what you
know why are you interested in free
markets and why in existentialism yeah
so I stumbled into it I suppose I don't
think that I'd be fortunate enough to be
sitting here talking to you or to have a
job in academia if my original plan was
to promote free market existentialism
because the existentialist establishment
wouldn't have me that that's for sure so
my my original interest is in philosophy
of existentialism and I like to be left
alone I like not to have a scripted life
I don't like to be told how to live I
always thought politics was basically
goofy and I wanted to be left alone from
it and I suppose the older I got the
more I realized that was not being left
alone both economically and socially and
became more interested in social
philosophy and economics and thought
that i found the philosophy that dubbed
the economics and social philosophy that
dovetailed best with my existentialism
was actually free market libertarianism
well that is a fascinating and the book
is the free market existentialist
capitalism without consumerism bill
thanks for talking to us thanks so much
Nick we've been talking with William
Irwin he is the author of the free
market existentialist capitalism without
consumerism for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie